Donald Trump of course is named in the
court documents but before we're not
going to bury the lead it seems to be
more exculpatory so far and I will say
this first and foremost you find in
these court
documents evidence and accusations
against Donald Trump I am alongside you
know I will say be it him or dtz or
anybody else investigate lock up anybody
who was engaged in this trafficking but
cursory search all light did to control
F Trump and what do we find so there
were a few instance uh initially they
say U Maxwell said this is the in the
closer to the beginning of the document
uh Jeffrey Epson who is a friend of
Donald Trump so I figured well he was a
good guy or whatever you know and what
she was going to learn and she was going
to learn massage therapy did Virginia
tell you this oh I can tell you uh I
can't tell you what date and time blah
blah blah so Trump is passively
mentioned here the next instance of his
mention is this uh uh this is a court
statement not an interview the other the
other portions of the of the court
records are uh interview interview with
Witnesses and victims